the United States aircraft carrier USS
Nimitz has arrived in South Korea a day
after North Korea fired two short-range
ballistic missiles off its East Coast
USS Nimitz is now in the port of Busan
the nuclear-powered aircraft carrier has
been conducting military exercises with
South Korea in international waters
let's go live to the warship now
altazarus Robert McBride is aboard tell
us more about these exercises and what
the USS limits is doing there Rob
because really it's that's right this
Nimitz has arrived here Tuesday the
media have been invited on board there's
a press conference going on at the
moment from both the U.S Navy and their
South Korean counterparts if we know Pan
the camera a little bit and give you a
view of the flight deck here we are
restricted to one area of the flight
deck but it really is a massive ship one
of the biggest warships ever built it is
the iconic nuclear-powered aircraft
carrier and uh getting on in years it's
something like 50 years old now the uh
Nimitz it had been in service that long
and it was a sister ship of the Nimitz
another nimitz-class carrier that was
last here that was last September when
we had the Ronald Reagan uh visiting uh
Busan and that was the first carrier to
be on exercise in uh South Korean waters
for around five years so this is quite a
significant uh return this Nimitz battle
group has been on exercises the past few
days off the southern as Korean island
of JeJu it has been doing about this
same time yesterday Monday it was doing
um aircraft drills launching aircraft
off this flight deck having them being
returned again it's all part of these
joint military exercises which I've been
very extensive they're a resumption
after a Hiatus of a few years to allow
possible partly for the covid pandemic
but also to allow dialogue to happen
with North Korea but the exercises have
come back in scale this spring we're
having air exercises with some of the
latest Jets we're also having uh in
cooperation with nuclear-capable bombers
from the U.S U.S Air Force we're all
also been seeing live fire drills with
some of the armor that's based here on
the peninsula and tomorrow Wednesday we
will be seeing an amphibious Landing
drill by Marine units to show us that
capability so really are resuming in
scale these large joint military
exercises between South Korean and U.S
forces here and Rob tell us more about
North Korea's reaction to these ongoing
exercises
as you would expect the reaction from
North Korea has been characteristically
bellicose it has accused uh the South
Koreans and the U.S of warmongering they
see these exercises as being a Prelude
to war a preparation for Invasion and of
course it has been showing its
displeasure with all of these multiple
launches uh yesterday Monday we had the
launch of two short-range missiles but I
think what's been interesting the past
couple of weeks is just a full range of
missiles that has been launched at the
other end of the missile Spectrum you've
had the launch of an intercontinental
ballistic missile that was a couple of
weeks ago to show displeasure at the
start of these exercises that was
presumed to have been a giant Hua song
17 it's the very latest type of
intercontinental ballistic missile that
North Korea has developed capable it
said of reaching the continental United
States and then possibly of more concern
to neighbors such as South Korea and
also Japan has been the development of
shorter range tax practical missiles as
the kind of cruise missiles which are
able are a lot harder to detect and
intercept also missiles launched from
submarines and in the last couple of
days another type of under underwater
drone which the North Koreans say is
capable of creating a radioactive
tsunami so all of these different types
of missiles are of concern not only to
the U.S with a lot the development of
longer range missiles but certainly to
North Korea's neighbors with some of
this shorter arsenal of missiles that
are being developed now how to say it
was Robert McBride aboard the USS Nimitz
in Busan South Korea many thanks indeed
Rob